اهلا بكم الى بانوراما انا ميسون عزام
احييكم مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
بعد سيطره الطالبان هجمات لداعش مظاهرات
نسائيه ضغوط دوليه وعقوبات متوقعه هل تعود
افغانستان قاعده للارهاب وتهديدا للامن
العالميه تنازلات بشار الاسد السياديه
لطهران مجرد ضغوط ايرانيه ام حقيقه واقعه
ولماذا لم تتم الزياره المقرره للرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي الى دمشق سيف
الاسلام القذافي يعود الظهور مطالبا بفتح
باب الترشح للرئاسه فهل ظهورهم مجددا
يساعد في حل الازمه الليبيه ام يؤدي لمزيد
من خلف الاوراق
[موسيقى]
اذا افغانستان تحت حكم طالبان لم تختلف عن
ما كانت عليه في الفتره الاولى من الحكم
الطالباني بين عامي
1996و 2001 مع عوده حركه طالبان الى
السلطه في عام 2021 عادت افغانستان الى
مربع الصفر وعهود القهر رغم الوعود
والتعهدات التي تحدث عنها المسؤولون في
الحركه في اولى ايامهم حاله من الفوضى
والاضرابات الامنيه وانفجارات واغتيالات
اعلنت داعش المسؤوليه عن بعضها ابرز اشكال
الاضطهاد وانتهاكات حقوق الانسان كانت من
نصيب المراه بعد ان ظهرت جميع قرارات
طالبان وكانها ترفع شعارا واحدا لا مكان
للنساء في البلاد عام وبضعه اشهر من حكم
طالبان في العهد الجديد برزت فيه طالبان
بذات الوجه القديم لا للتعليم لا للعمل
والكثير الممنوعات الحياه وتقييد الحريات
فوضى واضطرابات داخليه صعد منها الحكم
الطالباني وتهدد بان تعيد هذا البلد مجددا
ملاذا للارهاب وخطرا على الداخل المطهد
والامن العالمي
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من القاهره الدكتور
احمد قنديل الباحث في الشؤون الاسيويه
اهلا بك ومعنا من الدمام عبراسكايب السفير
سيد جلال كريم سفير افغانستان لدى
السعوديه سابقا اهلا بك وابدا معك ساعات
السفير نتحدث عن شكل الحكم الان في
افغانستان مع طالبان نتحدث عن طالبان
جديده ام الوجه القديم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
في الحقيقه انا اعتقد ان الحركه الطالبان
والحكومه الافغانيه الحالي يعني في بعض
الامور وكثير من الامور يختلف من عهدهم
السابقه اولا ااا علاقاتهم الدوليه في
الوقت الحاضر وعلاقتها ثم جيرانهم يعني
علاقات تقريبا شبه ممتازه مع كافه الدول
المنطقه مثلا علاقات مع روسيا علاقات مع
الصين باكستان علاقات مع هند مع تركيا مع
اوزباكستان تركمان
قليلا مع ايضا ايران
فهذا طبعا خطوه للامام للحكومه الحاليه
الافريقي انه الحكومه السابقه ما كان
عندها حل مرونه هذا الشيء الثاني انه احنا
نشوف انه الدول الاوروبيه بلا استثناء
تقريبا اليابان همم نرويه والمانيا وغيرهم
كلهم هل يوجد لديهم سفارات يتعاملون مع
الحكومه يوجد هناك الدعم مادي 40 مليون
دولار اسبوعيا للحكومه الحاليه سواء كان
ذاك مباشر او عن طريق المنظمات الجامعه
المدنيه
فاعتقد بان
الوضع الحركه في الوقت الحاضر هو افضل من
السابق ولكن
نشوف انه بعض القرارات اللي تم استخراجها
من الحكومه الحاليه اطلق المجتمع الدولي
لكن انا بالنسبه لي شخصيا
سيد جلال اسمح لي ولكن لا حط انه في تعليق
من السيد احمد قنديل ااه يعلق بدايه ليس
فقط على القرارات ولكن حتى ما ذاكرته فيما
يتعلق بالعلاقات
اتفضل سيد احمد
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى ضيفك كريم وعلى
مشاهدي قناه العربيه في كل مكان بدون شك
بعدد من دول العالم احتفظت ببعثتها
الدبلوماسيه في كابول بعد عوده
طالبان للسيطره على زمام الامور في اغسطس
2021 ولكن لم تعترف بها اي دوله حتى الان
يعني رغم الاحتفاظ مثل هذا التواجد
الدبلوماسي الا انه لا توجد دوله واحده من
الدول التي تفضل سعاده السفير بسكرها
اعترفت بطبعها ربما يعود ذلك الى حد كبير
الى عدم الثقه في هذا النظام وعدم الثقه
في وعوده التي قدمها الى المجتمع الدولي
عندما جاء الى السلطه والتي اثبتت الايام
انه لم يفي باي منها على سبيل المثال
مساله همم
تكوين حكومه تمثيليه لجميع طوائف الشعب
الافغاني وتاخذ في همم حسبانيها جميع
ارقيات والاستينيات الموجوده في البلاد
اعطاء المراه حقوقها العادله والمتساويه
مع الرجال خصوصا فيما يتعلق بحق التعليم
وحق همم العمل وغيرها مساله همم يعني همم
الاحترام حقوق الانسان وغيرها من الوعود
التي لم يجد المجتمع الدولي اي منها ينفذ
على ارض الواقع ايضا همم شاهدنا التدهورا
كبيرا في الاوضاع الامنيه وعدم احكام
سيطره طالبان على الاراضي الافغانيه وربما
كانت الهجمات الاخيره التي تم تنفيذها في
الشهور الاخيره من جانب تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه سواء ضد الفندق الذي يرتده رجال
الاعمال الصينيون منذ حوالي همم اسبوعين
او الهجمات ضد السفارات بين الباكستانيه
والروسيه والتي اسفرت عن وقوع ضحايا
وبالتالي حتى الكرت الوحيد التي كانت
طالبان من حيث كونها المحافظ على الامن
والاستقرار وعدم ااا السماح لاي التنظيمات
ارهابيه بالعمل من داخل اراضي الافغانيه
حتى هذا الامر الوحيد بدات تصدير والتعامل
مع المجتمع الدولي اسمح لي يا دكتور احمد
لانه السيد همم سيد جلال كان يتحدث عن
المرونه بعض الشيء يبدو سيد جلال ان
المرونه لا تكفي الان في ظل سقوط بحسب ما
يقولوا الاستاذ احمد كل الاوراق الموجوده
ان كان في ما يتعلق بخذلان همم المجتمع
الداخلي او همم دوليا في ما يتعلق
بالقرارات والوعود على مستوى حكومه
اقتصاده وايضا على مستوى امنيه
قد اختلف مع الدكتور في بعض الامور اولا
لما نتكلم عن دعم دولي 40 مليون دولار
شهريا اسبوعيا فهذا مبلغ ليس بسيط جدا
وتقريبا اكثر من مليار دولار مليار ونص
دولار ثانويه هذا شيء واحد شيء ثاني انه
لا نتوقع اولا الدكتور قال انه هناك
التزام كانوا من حركه طالبان انه يدخلونا
الكافه اطراف الافغانيه في الحكومه
الحكومه طبعا اتفاق دعاء النصف ذلك على
رغم ضغط الدولي عليهم في وقت الاتفاق ولكن
ما قبل هم على الكلام هذا ولكن تابعنا
احنا همم يعني نتمنى يوجد هناك في الدين
الاسلامي وفي كل المجتمعات تعريف واضح
الحقوق الانسان حقوق المراه حقوق التعليم
فلاشكه بان حق التعليم وحق المراه وحق عمل
المراه هي حقوق لا غبار عليها
لكن طريقه التطبيق هذا الحقوق لكل دوله
لها يعني طريقتها في الداخل داخل البلد
مثل هذه الخطوه باعتبار افغانستان بوضعها
الحالي لها خصوصيتها
انا واضح جدا كلامي واضح انه للمراه حق
التعليم للمراه حق العمل لكل الفرض في
المجتمع لهم حق واضح يعني يجب ان يحترم
هذا الحقوق بكافه انواعها على حكومه
الطالبان
لتعليم المراه همم
ولكن في نفس الوقت انا مجتمع الدول الدولي
ادراك بان داعش والمنظمات الارهابيه في
العراق تحالف كامل من كافه الدول والجيش
العراقي وبامكانات الماليه 100 مليار
دولار داخل الحكومه العراقيه سنوي ما
قدروا يحاربون داعش والمنظمات
فلا نتوقع انه كان طالبان لوحدهم بدون دعم
مجتمع الدولي امنيا يقدر يحاربون داعش
والمنظمات الارهابيه لوحدها بدون دعم دول
ما اظن انه ممكن طالبان لوحدهم يقدر
يحاربون داعش لازم
دكتور احمد نقطه مهمه في ما يتعلق بالامن
يعني باكثر من دوله حتى دول كبرى ولديها
جيوش داعش استطاع ان يخترق هذه الدول فما
بل افغانستان اللي خرج منها الامريكان
وطالبان لا زالت دعنا اضعها في هذا الاطار
وليدا الان في اعاده حكمها على الارض
طريقه الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان
ربما تكون همم احد العوامل الاساسيه التي
ساعدت في عدم قدره همم السلطه المركزيه في
كابول على احكام سيطرتها على البلاد وربما
ايضا هناك عامل اخر مهم في هذا الامر وهو
التنافس الجيوسي سياسي مع
الصين وروسيا في افغانستان من جانب الوقت
المتحده الولايات المتحده تضع الدولتين
حاليا باعتبارهما اهم التهديدات والتحديات
همم للامن القومي الامريكي وبربما يكون
عدم استدباب الامن والاستقرار في
افغانستان احد القرود المهمه التي يمكن ان
توظفها واشنطن في صراحه مع هاتين مع
الدولتين الجارتين والثاني توجد العديد من
التقديرات والتقارير التي تتحدث
امريكيه بقصده او بدون بغض النظر هل لماذا
تسمح الصين ولماذا تسمح روسيا ان كان عن
قصد من قبل الولايات المتحده او بدون قصد
ان تصبح وتعود ربما افغانستان ساحه
للارهاب
حضرتك السؤال لي ولا لحضرتك بس همم
سيد جلال
سيدنا اتفضل
لا اعتقد ان الدولتين في موسكو او بكين
ترغبين في انتشار الفوضى في افغانستان
ربما يكون ذلك سبب مصارعاتهم لفتح قنوات
اتصال مع طالبان بعد خروج القوات
الامريكيه وربما ساهم ذلك ايضا في ماده
بعض المعونات الاقتصاديه والوعود بمشروعات
استثماريه كبيره في حال استدباب الامن
والاستقرار هناك
وهذا اعتقد لاعب الى حد كبير دورا في
اخماد الفوضى والتوتر ولكن مع
الحرب الاوكرانيه ومع انتشار ال- ال- ال-
المصاعب الاقتصاديه في الصين ربما تراجع
هذا الاهتمام همم له اولويه تاليه لاتين
دولتين وبالتالي من المتوقع في الفتره
القادمه استمرار
وتفاقم هذه الفوضى والتوتر همم في في
تقدير يعني
يدفعنا للتساؤل عن مستقبل افغانستان
ضل هذا الوضع واعود اليك سيد جلال همم
ربما تركت عن قصد او بدون قصد افغانستان
الان لكي تتعامل مع الوضع الامني ماذا
تتوقع
همم انا شخصيا اعتقد ان يوجد هناك
اختلافات بين حركه طالبان والايات المتحده
الامريكيه في تطبيق الدوحه همم لانه لغايه
الان همم الدعم الوحيد همم
يتم همم اعطاها للحكومه الافغانيه الحاليه
تم من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والدول الاوروبيه اللي هو 40 مليون دولار
تقريبا اسبوعيا اما الصين وروسيا والدول
الاخرى المجاوره الافغانستان ادعمهم يعتبر
دعم بسيط جدا وصغير فاحنا من هذه الدعم
احنا نرى ان الدول الاوروبيه واو المتحده
الامريكيه عند اهتمام همم في افغانستان
وايضا طالبان علاقاتها مع روسيا والصين
والدول الجوار نسوي نوع من التوازن ما عدا
تجكسان تجيك الثانيه يتدخل في شؤون
الافغانيه بالدعم المعارضه الحاليه فاعتقد
ان هذا الدعم سوف يكون سبب للمشاكل
مستقبلا في حاله عدم تدخل روسيا همم ودول
غربيه اخرى للوقف طاجكستان وعدم دعم
المعارضه لكي يبدا مره ثانيه من جديد همم
يعني همم الحب ضد الحكومه الافغانيه ولكن
احب ااكد ان طالبان مثل اي دوله اخرى
اعطينا مثال ايران واعطينا مثال ليبيا
واعطينا مثال الدول اخرى يحتاجون الى دعم
المجتمع الدولي لمحاربه داعش والقاعده
اخرى هذا شيء بدونها سوف يكون صعب للحكومه
توها ما عنده مشاكل ماديه عندها همم مقاطع
يعني ماليه مقاته في التحويلات البنكيه
وغيرها من البقاعات صعب ان يحاول انه حرب
داعش والقائد الواحد
جلال كريم سفير افغانستان لدى السعوديه
سابقا شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ضيفي من
القاهره الدكتور احمد قنديل الباحث في
الشؤون الاسيويه
[موسيقى]